اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما وفي عناوين ملفات النقاش لهذا
المساء
12 يوما تفصل ايران عن قنبلتها النوويه
وفقون فهل انتهت اتفاق 2015 واين ذهبت
تعهدات الغرب بمنع ايران من امتلاك السلاح
المحظور
في الملف الثاني مواجهه عسكريه كبرى في
الشرق الاوسط نعمه تحقق مصالح روسيا
وايران وتخدم استراتيجيه الصين فهل تعمل
موسكو وطهران على اشعال مواجهه عسكريه في
المنطقه
وفي الملف اساس تطور عسكري غير مسبوق
مسيارته كياف تصل اطرف موسكو فهل يختبر
الغرب قدره بوتين ام ان مرحله نقل الحرب
الى الاراضي الروسيه قد بدات بالفعل
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل تقدم لافت احرزته
ايران في برنامجها النووي منذ خروج
الولايات المتحده عام 2018 من الاتفاق
المبرم عام 2015
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون اعلنت
ان ايران كانت تحتاج لثني عشر شهرا لانتاج
قنبله نوويه في 2018 واليوم تحتاج فقط الى
12 يوما لانتاج المواد الانشطاريه اللازمه
لصنع قنبله نوويه واحده وكيل وزاره الدفاع
لشؤون السياسات
املا ضئيلا متبقيا لحل هذه المشكله
دبلوماسيان واعاده القيود على برنامج
ايران النووي وهذا برايه افضل من الخيارات
الاخرى ولكن في الوقت الحالي فان خطط
العمل الشامله المشتركه مجمده مضيفا بان
روسيا لن تضغط على ايران للوصول للاتفاق
النووي الجديد بسبب علاقه البلدين التي
باتت اكثر قرب منذ اندلاع الحربي في
اوكرانيا تصريحات كولين كال جاءت خلال
جلسه بمجلس النواب بعد ان الح عليه نائب
جمهوري لمعرفه السبب وراء سعي اداره
الرئيس جو بايدن لاحياء الاتفاق الذي يعرف
باسم خطه العمل للشامله المشتركه وكاله
الطاقه الذريه اكدت ان مخزونه ايران من
اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه مختلفه او بنسب
مختلفه زاد بنحو 87 كلغ منذ اخر تقرير
فصلي ليصل الى اكثر من
3760 كيلوغراما ومع اقتراب ايران من
القنبله النوويه الاولى تطرح تساؤلات حول
مصير التعهدات الغربيه المتكرره من
الولايات المتحده واوروبا بمنع ايران من
امتلاك السلاح النووي وما الخطوات التي
سيقوم بها الغرب خلال 12 يوما فقط
ايران قنبله نوويه وشيكه قلق امريكي حيال
التقدم المفاجئ للبرنامج النووي الايراني
ايران وصلت في الاشهر الاخيره زياده
مخزونها من اليورانيوم المخصب تقرير
لوكاله الطاقه الذريه مخزون ايران من
اليورانيوم المخصب يتجاوز 18 مره السقف
المسموح به المخزون ارتفع مع الثاني عشر
من فبراير الى
3760 كيلو جراما مقابل
3673 كجما في اكتوبر الماضي طهران لم نجري
اي محاوله تخصيب فوق نسبه 60%
مناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من باريس ناصر
زهير المحلل السياسي اهلا بك من تل ابيب
ايلون ابيتار سابق في وزاره الامن
الاسرائيليه اهلا بكم ضيوفي واسمح لي ان
ابدا مع صيد فياتار صيده فياتار ما ورد من
تفاصيل هل يعلن نهايه الاتفاق النووي لعام
2015 وتعذر احيائه كما كان الغرب يود او
يطمح
بكل بصراحه او بكل صراحه انه هذه العيلان
الاعلان الامريكي ما
له اهميه اكيد بس ما بيغير التفاهم او
الفهم الاسرائيلي
والانتاجات الاسرائيليات بالنسبه
للتكدم السريع الايراني لكنبله نوويه
باسرائيل بيقول له من كم شهور خمسه سته
شهور انه ايران موجوده في
سبيل مباشر وسريع
مع كل الجهود من اجل الوصول الى قنبله
نوويه واليوم سمعنا
مندوبين
امريكاني من امريكا انه هذه
يساغه هذه
السياسه الايرانيه موجوده في نقطه النهايه
اسرائيل فهمت مشمس مش بس من اليوم عفوا
انه
من ناحيه ايرانيه ما في اي
مش جاهزه لاي مفاوضات لاي
استراحه لاي تعديل
القدره
واسرائيل تامل انه
امريكا تشتغل او
بتكون معي اسرائيل بنسبه للهدف المركزي
وهو
وقف او تعطيل
البرنامج الاغانيه طيب سيد زهير
اثنى عشر يوما على امتلاك ايران سلاح او
قنبله نوويه
هذا التصريح للبنتاجون خطير وملفت جدا هل
تعتقد بان هذا التقرير اكيد بانه سيقول
قائل مبني على دلائل ولكن يضعنا في اي
اطار من الخطوره
نعم تحياتي للجميع يعني في المسار الاساسي
لهذه التقارير الامريكيه التي كنا نتابعها
دائما بعد انسحاب الولايات المتحده من
الاتفاقنا ومنذ عام 2018 كانت هناك تقارير
تقول بان ايران على بعد اسابيع او اشهر من
امتلاك المواد الاساسيه لصنع القنبله
النوويه هناك خطوره بالتاكيد في هذا
التقرير ولكن انا اعتقد بان ايران لا زالت
بعيدا نوعا ما عن الوصول الى القنبله
النوويه يعني اذا ما كانت تقرير يعني يقول
دقيق في تقييمه 12 يوما حتى الوصول الى
مواد الانشطاريه اللازمه هناك ايضا وقت
يتطلب الى الوصول الى القنبله النوويه
واذا ما كان هناك اراده اساسا دعني اقول
للاعلان الان او التوصل الى مثل هذه
القدره النوويه لايران ولكن هناك خطوره
بالتاكيد لامتلاك ايران لهذا السلاح واذا
كان هذا التقرير دقيق فالاداره الامريكيه
اعتقد بانها ستعمل على منع ايران من
الوصول الى هذه القدره النوويه خلال الوقت
المتبقي سواء كان ايام او لا تشكك في
تصريحاتها تعتقد بان هذه التصريحات
اهدافها لما تقول بانه ان كان دقيق ما
الغايه من تقديم مثل هكذا تقارير
الغايه هي في الصراع الدائر في الداخل
الامريكي بمعنى بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين هل نذهب الى مفاوضات نوويه
مع ايران بتنازلات محدده ام او اتفاق سريع
واحياء للخطه الشامله ام نبقى في المسار
الاساسي وتشديد العقوبات هو قال بانه
ايران في 2018 كانت بعيده 12 شهرا الان 12
يوما يعني هو تحذير بانه انا اعتقد بان
هذه خطوات الادارات الديمقراطيه سواء كان
منذ اوباما واتفاقه مع ايران حول برنامج
نووي الى بايدن الان والخطوات التي يقوم
بها اذا ما كان هناك اعلان مفاجئ في
الايام القادمه او عوده مفاجئه او ايا كان
من هذه المسارات فان في الداخل الامريكي
يقول حتى امام الراي العام بان هذا مبرر
لان ايران على قرب من امتلاك القنبله
النوويه وبالتالي يجب منعها او يجب سحبها
خطوه الى الخلف من اجل التوقيع على
الاتفاق ولكن ايضا في الاطار الاساسي يجب
عدم تقديم تنازلات كبيره وهذه رؤيه الدول
الاقليميه في المنطقه لايران حتى تذهب الى
اتفاق وتكون يدها مطلقه في البرنامج
الصواريخ البالستيه ودعم الميليشيات
وغيرها من النقاط التي هي ايضا تشبه في
خطورتها خطوره امتلاك القنبله النوويه هل
تتفق مع ضيفي على ان على الغرب سحب ايران
خطوه للوراء وفرز اتفاق نووي عليها
والسؤال الاخر هل هم قادرون على ذلك فعلا
هل الغرب قادر على ذلك
مع الاسف عندنا خبره خبره طويله
في اثبات على الوقت انه اسرائيل كمان ما
تؤمن باتفاق الاتفاق السابق من ناحيه غنيه
انه فشل من ناحيه غنيها كان بس من اجل
كوسيله منوعات سياسيه وتكتيكيه من ناحيه
غنيه على العالم وعلى مجتمع الغربي
مياهيا بالفعل لاتفاق لسابك ما نجح بالهدف
السلفيه وابشان هيك اسرائيل كمان ما تؤمن
باي اتفاق جديد
بين دول الغرب وايران
الاتفاق متابعي لتاريخ مش لمستقبل
وعشان هيك من ناحيه اسرائيليه ما في اي
امكانيه
او سياسه
لوصول او لشراكه
باتفاق جديد بين العالم وبين ايران
التاريخ بيثبت اشي تاني
بالعكس
معناته هلا اسرائيل تستعد بكل القواتات
بكل الامكانيات وبكل الخيارات ما عمرك
تتامل انه بتنجح باجماع ولايات المتحده
بوقف كل امكانيه لاتفاق جديد
وخيار
خلينا نقول وسائل اضافيه
حسب وسائل السبيل العسكري
طيب سيد زهير قبل ان نصل الى المتوقع ان
كان هناك تحرك عسكري ضيف يطرحه على الاقل
البعض الاخر يستبعده ولكن من يتحمل
مسؤوليه فشل اتفاق 2015 فشل اعاده وضعها
على الطاوله وخاصه فشل منع ايران من عملها
للحصول على قنبله نوويه البعض يوجه اصابع
الاتهام للغرب
هنا يجب ان نميز من هو هذا الغرب الذي
نتحدث عنه يعني بمعنى اذا تحدثنا عن الغرب
نتحدث عن دول الاوروبيه والولايات المتحده
انا اعتقد بان الولايات المتحده هي
المسؤوله عن فشل منع ايران منام الوصول
الى او من امتلاك القنبله النوويه لانه
بامى عندما وقع اتفاق عام 2015 وقع اتفاق
منقوص للغايه اتفاق لا يضمن تفكيك المنشات
المفاعلات نوويه الايرانيه اتفاق بحسب
دعيني اقول اعترافات مسؤولين ايرانيين
رفيعين مستوى كانوا يعدون لتشغيل
المفاعلات النوويه باقصى سرعه ممكنه عند
الانسحاب من هذا الاتفاق او عند اي خطر
وبالتالي توقيع اوباما الاتفاق منقوص هو
ما تسبب ايضا في هذه الازمه التي نتحدث
عنها ايضا اداره اوباما تاخرت كثيرا في
اتخاذ خطوات حاسمه ضد ايران سواء كان ما
يتعلق في مساله العقوبات والضغوطات
الدوليه حتى الضغوطات الدوليه على حلفاء
ايران اذا ما تحدثنا عن الصين وروسيا لان
الولايات المتحده قايضت الصين في كثير من
المناسبات وفي كثير من القضايا وكان
يمكنها فعل ذلك ايضا في قضيه ايران ولذلك
الان تحمل المسؤوليه او من هو المسؤول هي
الادارات الديمقراطيه بين قوسين حول هذا
الوضع النقطه الاخرى الان ما هي الخيارات
وكيف سيتم التعامل مع ايران يعني دائما ما
يتم طرح المعادله التاليه الان من هو
الاخطر او ما هو السيناريو الاخطر ان
نتعامل مع ايران تمتلك قدره نوويه ام
نتعامل مع ايران في اتفاق نووي منقوص يطلق
يدها في المنطقه بتمويل اكثر من 100
وخمسين مليار دولار سنويا ودعمها
للميليشيات والمسيرات وزعزعه استقرار
المنطقه نعتقد بان السيناريو الثاني اخطر
من السيناريو الاول لان وين وصلت ايران
الى القدره النوويه يمكن تحجمها بين قوسين
لتكون كوريا الشماليه الثانيه الموجوده
الان المحاصره التي تمتلك اسلحه نوويه
ولكن لا يمكنها حتى يعني يقول تهديد حقيقي
لكوريا الجنوبيه على سبيل المثال وهذه هي
المعادله الان التوصل الى الضغط على
ايراني معناها من امتلاك القنبله هو
السيناريو واحد ثانيا عدم تقديم تنازلات
في اي مفاوضات متوقعه لان هذه التنازلات
ستكون خطيره جدا في سياسات ايران نقطه
ملفته في الواقع طرحتها استاذ زهير لما
قربت بين امتلاك ايران نووي وبين توسع
ايران وهنا سؤال سيد ايلون هل تتفق مع
ضيفي على ان امتلاك ايران النووي قد يكون
اقل خطوره من توسعها وتمددها في المنطقه
وربما امكانيه
امن وسلامات هذه المنطقه
في موضوعين مهمه بالنسبه لهذه السؤال اول
شيء من المهم التاكيد انه من ناحيه
اسرائيليه وصول ايران الى قنبله نوويه هاي
تهديد وجوده
عشان هيك والساعه تذوق ولكن ولكن الاستاذ
زهير يقول يمكن تحجيمها كما فعل المجتمع
الدولي لكوريا الشماليه
وكمان نقطه ثانيه وموضوع ثاني هو مش بس
الموضوع
النووي هو كمان
التقدم الصغير من كل نواحي من ايران في
الجبل الشماليه
خلينا نقول تهديد عسكري على اسرائيل من
سوريا ومن لبنان
بكل النواحي ونحن شايفين انه من ناحيه
غنيه ما في اي امكانيه لوقف هذه الهجومه
وهذه السبيل العسكري
انت كرامته كانك تصر على فرضيه ان يتحرك
الغرب او على الاقل بدفعا من اسرائيل
عسكريا هل هذا السناريو مطروح باختصار انت
كرمت
اسرائيل ما تمشي بمجال العسكر لحالها
وحدها اسرائيل تحتاج لشركه اسرائيل تحتاج
لوحدها مع الغرب وخاصه مع امريكا
بسبيل العسكر وكمان بهجوم من كل النواحي
كمان بالمجال الاستخباري ضد ايران وما في
اي وقت اللي لعب ما في اي وقت لتدريس من
الاول عشان هيك في هدف وهذه الهدف لازم
نشتغل بوصول الى هذه الهدف بكل الجهود
جهود المشتركه وضحت الفكره شكرا جزيلا لك
من تل ابيب يا ترى امنه سابق في وزاره
الامن الاسرائيليه وشكر كذلك لضيفه من
باريس ناصر زهير المحلله السياساسي شكرا
لكما
[موسيقى]